[Applause]
that's one small step for
man one Le for man according to new
research about one in 10 Canadians
believe Neil Armstrong's famous step
down was actually a giant leap in
deception add to that the more recent
belief that covid was developed as a
bioweapon and its sister falsehood that
government are covering up dangers about
the vaccine about a third of Canadians
appear to believe in both of those
things since the Adit of Co we we saw a
tremendous leap in the belief in
conspiracy theories Steve mossop's
latest Le poll turned up staggering
levels of belief in things that either
aren't supported by evidence or are just
plain wrong take the assassination of
President Kennedy the classic rock of
conspiracy theories Le found 36 % of
Canadians believe it was a coverup
similar for the death of Princess Diana
34% told Le they have it on good
authority that Diana's death was not
accidental you are fake news sir go
ahead and since you're watching this on
the news you ought to know that a
whopping 55% of Canadians now believe
the mainstream media manipulates the
information it puts out with Co and with
President Trump calling fake news
there's been this erosion of trust uh
the perception of media not only in our
country but in the USA as well so what's
driving the tendency to believe in
Chemtrails or a flat Earth especially in
an age when it's never been easier to
get information mossup suspects the
single biggest driver is the way social
media algorithms work to reinforce what
you know or what you think you know
every time you turn on your phone and
look at something for for fun it's
reinforcing what you currently believe
and takes you even further in Vancouver
Paul Johnson Global
News